here's a very big deal that i i
realized early in my life
uh liberty is not a human yearning it is
not a human instinct
it is a it is a value that has to be
learned and taught the uh the the human
instinct is to be taken care of and
people will most hum hum
most human beings
would prefer to be taken care of than to
be free
that that's that's the way it is and
that is the reason the left wins every
almost everywhere in the world
how many american liberty countries are
there in in the western hemisphere
outside of the united states
canada used to be one not not any longer
and
that's what humans humans make the deal
i'll give you my freedom you give me
free health care i'll give you my
freedom you give me free education give
me free give me free give me free you
can have my freedom but you know if you
really look at it from
an evolutionary psychological
perspective it makes sense that's right
that's the reason you need a a higher
principle than evolution to guide your
life by which is why ultimately i do
believe this is a religious battle let's
let's talk about that too because um
one of my views there's a lot of people
who've described what the difference
between the left and the right is some
have said it's national nationalist
versus a globalist i don't think that's
that's correct it's a component some
have said it's authoritarian versus
libertarian it's a component some have
said interestingly we had stephen marsh
on the show he wrote the book the next
civil war and he said it's
in the united states there is a
multicultural democracy in a
constitutional republic
both can't co-exist in the same country
and i'm like that's that's an
interesting way to put it actually but
maybe just one component i believe uh
and i mentioned a moment ago that it's
the politically discerning those who
would challenge the news and try and
make sure they're correct versus those
who want to follow and fit in i think
one large component is
the christian moral framework versus
an absent moral framework and what i
mean by that is to go back to bill maher
the way i've described in the past bill
maher is an atheist he made the
documentary religious where he
challenges you know he asks people he
travels around trying to understand
bill maher will say he doesn't believe
in god as morality doesn't come from
that but his morality literally is based
in the bible not completely not all of
it i'm not saying that and i'm not
saying you need to be religious because
i'm not practicing religious in any way
any religion what i mean is why do we
have the value of innocent until proven
guilty
because we were raised by a culture that
valued that if you were raised in a
different culture on the side of the
planet they would not have the same
value in fact there have been many
countries that have said the inverse it
is better that 10 innocent people suffer
than one guilty person escape we in the
united states hold an inverted view of
that benjamin franklin said it is better
that 100 guilty persons escaped than one
innocent person suffer he was it was a
plan blackstone's formulation which is
10 people
blackstone's formulation it is better
that 10 guilty persons escape than one
innocent suffer is rooted in the story
of sodom and gomorrah literally in the
bible when when god says to lot if
there's but one righteous person i will
abraham to abraham there you go uh so
you know more than i do about that stuff
but um i i read about this because i
wanted to understand why do we have
these values in this country and so i
read about the fourth and fifth
amendment i read about the the
presumption of innocence i read some of
the writings from the founding fathers
and their views on it benjamin franklin
i read the praise for blackstone's
formulation
and then i discovered his formulation
was rooted in the bible and i said
that's fascinating these stories from
religion were carried on and left within
us by the the previous generation now
people like bill maher say they don't
believe in any of that stuff not
realizing
he would have never known of that
concept were it not passed down to him
when you look at other countries other
cultures on the other side of the planet
that did not have the same religious
values they don't have this if you look
at what's going on with communist china
and
other countries they have a presumption
of guilt you get locked up and then
we'll figure it out
so in this country it seems like
there came a point where we still are
mostly christian but many people aren't
really practicing and don't really know
what it means you get a generation of
people who say they're atheists but
still hold a lot of those christian
moral for a lot of that christian moral
framework and now we're entering a
period where you have a generation with
no moral framework at all and if there's
no moral framework then there is no
truth but power which is what we're
starting to see lie cheat and steal say
whatever you want get political power
that's the path and that's what i see
with the mainstream left the modern left
today
every word you said is correct uh
my first book i wrote when i was 25 it's
still the most widely read introduction
to judaism in english
and uh in it i wrote
about something i had read called cut
flower ethics
if you cut flowers from the soil that
nurtured them
you could look at the flower and for a
couple of days it looks like
it doesn't need the soil that nurtured
it
but it will wither and die
the same with ethics in the western
world they were nurtured in religious
judeo-christian soil you rip those
ethics from that soil they will last for
a generation or two just like the flower
will for a day or two and then they will
wither and die and that is exactly what
we are seeing happening now
and that is why the founders of the
country wrote that we have inalienable
rights from the creator there are no
inalienable rights from human beings
there are only inalienable rights if
there is something that transcends the
the human and that is the creator
the most hated video i ever made i know
it because i actually look at comments
i'm fascinated by comments
and the most hated and i and i have
hundreds and hundreds out there
including 50 at prageru where we have
over 500 i do one out of 10.
the most hated video i ever made was
uh i don't remember the exact title but
essentially if god did not say murder is
wrong is murder wrong
and it drives people crazy even though
the logic
i debated this at oxford many years ago
against the professor of moral
philosophy at oxford and he's an atheist
and he said of course prager is right if
there is no god there is no objective
morality only only subjective you can
say i believe murder is wrong i think
murder is wrong i feel murder is wrong
but you can't say murder is wrong only
if there is something that transcends
the human that says murder is wrong is
murder wrong
but how do you explain that to someone
who doesn't have the mental capacity to
understand it no or you mean a college
graduate
is that it that is the definition of not
having the mental capacity i'm not being
cute i i have said for years and i do
believe this sincerely for most people
not all
college makes you stupid oh i agree uh
i'm a high school dropout and the funny
thing is you are yes you made my day
i'm not joking
well so the left
they believe in credentialism and so
they'll often say don't listen to tim
who is a high school dropout that means
he's dumb and my attitude is like my
arguments are what proves i'm dumb like
if you think my arguments are bad and
they are bad then i'm dumb but if you
don't have an argument against what i've
said or you don't understand the
concepts behind them because you lack
the mental capacity i don't think the
issue is credentials or school i think
in my experience you can argue that many
high school dropouts tend not to succeed
but there are a lot of people who
realize
the system isn't working properly and in
my case i was building computers
programming video games i was playing
music and i just thought this does not
serve me in any way other than to drag
me down and so i just you know took
issue with it well i mean
sorry i i just call them indoctrination
centers that's exactly what they are and
i just kind of want to point out also
there's a lot of statistics when it
comes to people who believe in religion
people who have families and correlation
with not just overall happiness but
success in in life that i think are
absolutely worth talking about here as
well that provide a lot of different
perspective when it comes to you know a
lot of people coming up in this world i
want to i want to mention when you say
uh what cut flower is that what you
called it yeah cut flower ethics yeah
that's brilliant it perfectly describes
it perfectly that uh that's bill maher
to the t the way i see him that's right
he doesn't understand that his values
actually he's living on borrowed on
borrowed soil and the woke is a direct
result of his advocacy of rejecting this
moral framework
again i'm not saying that people need to
believe in god but i think you need to
understand your roots and where your
values come from so by the way forgive
me i just want to say
to the chagrin of many religious people
i almost only argue for the necessity of
god rather than the existence of god
because if i prove to you or not you
can't prove it but if i convince you god
exists i have done nothing
but if i c because the the number of
people who believe in god who are moral
idiots is very large however
if i convince you that god is morally
necessary and is necessary for meaning
in life the greatest urge human has he
has even more so than sex
then i have changed your life well this
is what's fascinating um and as i've
looked at the the ethos and the tenets
of the modern left there seems to be no
moral framework at all and they say
there is one but i'll give the example
of stop and frisk and red flag laws stop
and frisk new york said we want to stop
guns on the street and contraband
therefore the police now have the right
to randomly stop anyone and frisk them
it resulted in marginalized people as
the left said and it literally did
disproportionately targeted uh young
black men and latinos the argument from
bloomberg was they're the ones
committing the crime so that's what
you're gonna see now the whistleblowing
was that they actually were instructed
to target racial minorities so they kind
of leap frogged the the issue of here's
where the crime is to just target the
racial group that had a negative
consequence if that issue was bad red
flag laws exact same logic we got to get
guns off the street and stop dangerous
people from having them we can go into
your home and take your guns if we have
reason to believe that you're you know
unwell or a threat or a danger
if that happens in new york and it
happens in a bunch of place which i
think it already has you're going to
start seeing the exact same thing they
were already complaining about
if they say one is good and one is bad
but they're functionally identical or
one is actually
red flag laws are worse much worse but
they want them and stop and frisk is is
not as bad but it's the it's apocalyptic
there's no moral logic behind what
they're arguing for in which case i
don't know the point
if you know i think stop-and-frisk is
wrong beyond there okay so to to just
reinforce your point npr during 2020 or
2021 i assume 2020
actually devoted an hour
to a a woman who wrote a book
in defense of looting i i'm familiar um
correct i gotta tell you i was in
ferguson do not steal does not apply
if if you are
as i said
they don't divide the world between
right and wrong but between black and
white rich and poor if a black person
loots it's okay except in that community
because what really angered me about
that i'm fairly certain that article was
about ferguson
and what happened was
i was in ferguson and i watched a group
of young black men link arms to protect
a store from looters and when they were
asked by a journalist from al jazeera
why are you defending this store they
said we live here this is our community
these are our stores the people who are
looting don't live here and they are
robbing us they are stealing from us and
in many instances it's yuppies looting
it's right like the lawyers in new york
city that just by the way had their
charges dropped that firebombed a police
car so i'm in ferguson i know that
really yeah the people who were looting
in ferguson didn't live there many of
most of them and the these poor people
who lived in this area desperately
trying to protect their own stores from
an outside force destroying it and then
these leftists write articles defending
those who actually
attacked the black community that that
to me was one of the most despicable
displays i have ever seen to see these
young men say we're trying to do right
by our community and then they have them
right none of the looting is good
those young men were being robbed their
their community was being destroyed they
needed someone to come in and say stop
these violent riders and looters from
destroying these people's neighborhood
instead they said well it's actually a
good thing because they're doing it as
an act of rebellion against white
supremacy it feels like moral relativism
may be i think are you saying you may be
indicating that there's a moral absolute
this this but if there's no moral
absolute then
then it's then murder isn't wrong i'm
thinking about the romans emperor
constantine he basically became the
first christian which was rooted in
judaism which is thou shalt not kill but
he went and killed eastward and
conquered and murdered right the fact
that people
don't live by their own values does not
mean that the values are irrelevant
you are right you could point to any
number of religious people who have
screwed up their own religion
that is correct but you can't live
without the principles the in other
words a lot of christians kept slaves
but it was and this is a jew saying it
was christians who abolish slavery not
muslims not shintoists not confucianists
not hindus
and not atheists it was christians who
abolished uh slavery on planet earth is
it the situation where the tenets of
judaism that the ten commandments are
good to follow and unless
fill in the blank
i uh you you're really uh playing to my
passion
my life is devoted to having people live
by the ten commandments i have a great
new saying you wanna you wanna defund
the police have everybody live by the
ten commandments i wanna give an example
if i may because uh behind me i'm told
is my one of my volumes of my bible
commentary
if if every atheist listening read that
they would at least intellectually
appreciate what those of us who believe
the bible is the greatest book ever
written is about has nothing to do with
faith nothing that's why i call it the
rational bible
and uh i i begin my my preface as
follows when i was in my early 20s and
late teens i had issues with my parents
which is pretty common on earth
however i i honored my parents i showed
them respect all the time i never
deviated from that and there was a
reason and it was the only reason i
believed that god himself had commanded
me
to honor your father and mother i
believed i would be sinning against god
forget my parents
if i didn't show my parents honor even
if i had a hard time with them and i'm
telling you
this this is a classic example of what
the left is doing to the society by
getting rid of of the of the of the ten
commandments the divine origins of all
this
what we're seeing today is this is my my
field of study communism and fascism for
that matter nazism
every totalitarian movement begins by by
subverting parental authority and that
is what the left is doing in america
you subverting parental authority you
listen to the state
kids you listen to the leader kids you
don't listen to your parents kids oh
yeah and also a lot of authority figures
so when the russians the soviets took
over poland they got rid of a lot of
doctors they got rid of a lot of
teachers they got rid of a lot of
lawyers they got rid of a lot of
historians and just took them to siberia
or assassinated them because they were
the ones that were the most influential
in their society and they needed to get
rid of that in order to push the
communist doctrine and you know you know
it's brutal here i want to address that
there's uh i grew up in a neighborhood
chicago that had a lot of polish people
there's a lot of polish jokes
stereotypes about people being dumb
talking to luke it's a particularly
brutal origin the reason that stereotype
exists is because soviets killed all the
intellectuals well and then
by the way somewhat of a farce i
remember when when polish jokes were in
so i have two comments on that first i
studied in england uh my junior year in
college every single polish joke i heard
in america was an english joke about the
irish right who would not be not known
thank you so much
and there's another one
at the very time people were telling the
most polish jokes the brilliant pope was
polish pope pope john xxiii or is it
john paul ii john paul
one of the most brilliant men of of that
generation and uh lequalenza was polish
and and and carter's uh
head of security was big near brzezinski
polish who was the guy i studied under
at columbia ironically but uh
i don't understand why polish jokes ever
developed uh national it was it was
against just demeaning the people and um
actually police people actually have
some of the highest iq in the region
it's bigger brzezinski the national
security advisor actually had some very
interesting conversations with him on my
own personal channel but there's a lot
we could get into especially culturally
especially with poland thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you